Pokerers: I feel happy when I drive my bike
To the unknown.
Going away is everything.
More than 150,000 kilometers were cut
On land or sea.
I'm not planning well.
All I know is where I want to go.
From there, you will
I see what I am destined to see.
I will not go anywhere else soon.
My battery is down, but we're here now.
This is the spirit of adventure.
[Rock music loud]
I do not know where I will sleep.
I do not know what I will eat, or who I will meet.
This is the adventure for me.
Boy: Where are you from?
Bookers: I'm from the Netherlands.
If you are ready for this, you will encounter unique things.
I have to look at my life in a day
I say, "My life was wonderful."